really disgusting news out of North
Carolina about voter suppression and
disenfranchising voters to the point
that many including a judge are calling
what has happened in North Carolina Jim
Crow style voter suppression now as a
reminder there's no doubt at all that
the entire point of voter ID and
reducing early voting it's all about
helping Republicans let me remind you
when Republican Pennsylvania State
Representative Mike Turzai admitted this
in front of cameras in a speech that
voter ID is all about helping
Republicans remember this we are focused
on making sure that we meet our
obligations that we've talked about for
years pro-second amendment the castle
doctrine son first pro-life legislation
abortion facility regulations in 22
years done voter ID which is going to
allow Governor Romney to win the state
of Pennsylvania Don it's a surprise and
we know about the insanity of what has
gone on in North Carolina and I will
tell you about some of the latest
revelations their number one the
elections board chairman Bill mcanulty
tried to open a Sunday voting location
it was in a mostly white county where
there were areas of black churches were
black church members were going to go
vote after sunday services and
republicans instantly called mr. McNulty
a traitor following the blowback from
the Republicans mcnulty withdrew his
support for the sunday voting site we've
also learned that there has been a very
active effort by north carolina
republicans to push against early voting
to lobby for shorter voting hours for
early voting on weekends and evenings
and then there is also the push
generally to uh reduce the number of
locations increase the number of ID
requirements etcetera we generally knew
that so what's the news well the news is
that reuters has now obtained emails
through a public records request and you
don't have to look very far to realize
that this is very very political the
emails revealed that while Democrats
were lobbying for early voting hours and
more hours more locations publicly
completely in the open saying here's
what we want
here's why we wanted Republicans who
were lobbying against early voting we're
doing it privately because it's
obviously partisan if you are going to
do this as secretly as opposed to
publicly there's no doubt that there is
something wrong with what you're doing
or something unfair about what you're
doing something discriminatory about
what you're doing but that's not it the
problems in North Carolina are way
bigger than just restricting early
voting because we have now heard from US
District Judge Loretta Biggs who slammed
the ongoing voter purge that is going on
during a hearing late last week saying
that she was quote horrified by the
quote insane process by which voters
could be removed from the rolls without
their knowledge here's what you can do
in North Carolina and I did not know
about this pack if someone receives mail
at an address and it gets returned to
sender you can take the eat the mail
that has been returned to sender and go
to the Elections Commission and say
listen I set this person male the
register to vote at this address but
it's been returned to sender the mail is
undeliverable remove them from the voter
rolls that's all it takes it's
completely legal and this has been used
to actually purged and thousands of
voters mostly black Democrats who do you
think they're voting for in the election
in a completely legal manner now think
about this you can game this right you
can say all right here's what we're
gonna do uh we know that poor people are
disproportionately likely to move more
often we know that poor people are
disproportionately more likely not to
have a steady mailing address let's just
deliberately start sending out all sorts
of mail only to voters that we believe
would vote for Democrats it'll come back
as undeliverable and we will take that
and ask for them to be removed for the
voter rolls it's insane and really you
have to do something about that that
should not be legal right the solution
is not oh well they should be doing it
to Republicans to know this this should
not be legal this should not be a method
through which the individual can have
other people purged from voter rolls and
at least one judge is saying this is
insane and this is Jim Crow like it's
really just a sad reflection on your
RT that you can't win the war of ideas
you have to resort to these sorts of
tactics yeah it's not like they say oh
you know what it's just bad for people
to vote early voting early is
objectively a bad and immoral thing now
it's that they know that early voting
and any methods that will generally
increase turnout particularly for
disadvantaged individuals is likely to
help Democrats it's completely political
and it's completely partisan it's
disgusting and we this happens every
election will it make a difference
tomorrow is this going to swing one
state or two states or three states in a
way that is going to swing the entire
election I hope the answer is no I
really hope that the answer is no